bange minuten sekunden womöglich meine
damen und herren und wenn ich ihn nicht
moderieren müsste würde ich den atem
anhalten die richterin taylor spricht
bereits in london im prozess gegen boris
becker wir warten auf das urteil
sie sagte in ihrer abschlussrede zu
beginn ich habe die einwände die für sie
vorgetragen wurden in betracht gezogen
aber sie machten persönlich gebrauch vom
firmenkonto sie haben eigentum
unterschlagen versteckt so viel geld
ging verloren da sehen wir sie im büro
taylor die richterin als knallharte
richterin bekannter nina kirsch ist hier
bei mir im studio burkhard wenigen ist
unser rechtsbeistand hier und christian
schommers der biograf von boris becker
alle sind hier es wird möglicherweise
auch ein statement geben dann im
anschluss an die urteilsverkündung
die ja wie gesagt in wenigen sekunden
fallen könnte minuten wir wissen es
nicht genau wie sind auf jeden fall live
dabei und sie damit auch meine damen und
herren da sehen wir burkhardt christian
schommers den biografen von boris becker
was wird ihn in diesen sekunden durch
den kopf gehen
ein absolutes schicksal situation für
boris natürlich es geht um alles es geht
um und nass oder gnade es geht darum ob
er über jahre hinweg seine familie seine
kinder seine lebensgefährtin seine
ehefrau nicht mehr sehen kann kann
nichts mehr tun erwartet auf das urteil
jetzt im glaskasten ich möchte mich
nicht weniger rein versetzen
ich bin emotional tatsächlich auch
angetan ehrlicherweise weil dass es
irgendwann mal so weit kommen kann mit
boris dem versuch lange sieht schlimm
ich habe neue informationen aus dem
gerichtssaal bekommen von der richterin
die gerade immer noch spricht und dass
ein wort gefallen und zwar geldwäsche
sie sagt sie geht jetzt gerade jeden
einzelnen schuldspruch durch sie sagt
sie haben gelder unterschlagen dazu
hatten sie genug und viel zeit es gibt
keine regeln wie man richten muss ich
habe alles abgewogen geldwäsche kommt
damit rein sagt die richterin während
ihre aktionen diejenigen favorisierten
die sie bevorzugten so durften sie
solche entscheidungen nicht machen zwei
jahre zwei jahre und sechs monate haft
die frage ist zwei jahre und sechs
monate haft für diese vier punkten wir
warten jetzt noch ganz kurz ob das auf
bewährung oder wirklich haft aber so wie
es jetzt klingt
wie ich glaube wir müssen uns ganz kurz
noch mal 30 sekunden gedulden wir können
wir können locker bin ich wert bin ich
das urteil ist gefallen zwei jahre und
sechs monate haft
also es ist im prinzip so wie ich
erwartet habe ich habe gesagt so bis
drei jahre und zwei jahre sechs monate
bedeutet weil es im englischen recht
nach meinem kenntnisstand nicht anders
ist als im deutschen da gibt es keine
bewährung mehr bei einer strafe von über
zwei jahren das müsste jetzt nach meinem
kenntnisstand jedenfalls eine
gefängnisstrafe seien ja also wir haben
gerade ich habe gerade eine e-mail
gekriegt knast also bestätigt gefängnis
stand jetzt müssen wir davon ausgehen
dass boris becker zweieinhalb jahre ins
gefängnis muss aber es sind jetzt
wirklich minuten also ich kann das gar
nicht beschreiben ich weiß nicht wie es
ihnen geht ich weiß nicht wie es dir
geht thomas aber ich bin richtig also
ich habe schon das gefühl kriegt hier
zum flattermann weil man ja irgendwie
das sind das sind sekunden jedem schlag
auf schlag geht das hier aber
leider sieht es stand jetzt wirklich
sehr sehr düster aus für unseren
tennishelden für boris becker denn
zweieinhalb jahre haft das ist gerade
der stand und ich warte jetzt jede
sekunde warten wir hier auf weitere
informationen aus dem gerichtssaal
ehrlich gesagt wir sind natürlich ein
bisschen fassungslos natürlich müsse man
damit rechnen und sehr wenige haben es
ja gesagt dass es tatsächlich dazu
kommen könnte aber wenn boris becker
zwei jahre und sechs monate ins
gefängnis gehen muss ist dass das
tatsächlich womit sie wirklich gerechnet
der kunde ganz kurz jetzt die neue info
angeblich soll er nach der hälfte raus
kommen sprich er könnte die hälfte der
zeit dann auf bewährung absitzen das ist
jetzt der aktuelle stand und da stehen
schon die mikrofone bereit für die
presseerklärung die dann gleich in
london vor dem southwark crown court
kommen wird
herr wenigen ist das gibt es in
deutschland natürlich auch nur das muss
man sagen also mit der hälfte ist es so
in deutschland kann man auch nach der
halben strafe entlassen werden das gab
es zum beispiel auch bei uli hoeneß das
war nur 50 prozent abgesetzt und wenn
die richterin dass im urteil in england
schon anordnen sollte ist das natürlich
sage ich mal schon ein gewisses
entgegenkommen in deutschland wird das
erst zu einem späteren zeitpunkt
entschieden man muss aber eins noch mal
ganz da sagen wenn es jetzt diese
gefängnisstrafe sein sollte von zwei
jahren und sechs monaten das war
abzusehen nach dem was in den letzten
tagen passiert ist und man muss auch
sagen das ist ja auch nicht weit von
abedi rumbeck und meines erachtens
tragen boris becker mit seinem verhalten
und sein verteidiger mit der strategie
die völlig nach hinten losgegangen ist
dann entscheidende mitverantworten
unglaublich unter tennisheld der held
unserer jugend der held vieler vieler
menschen boris becker mit 17 jahren
wimbledon gewonnen sensationell wird
jetzt dort in london an diesem ort
seines größten triumphes zu zweieinhalb
jahren gefängnis fordert man kann das
überhaupt gar nicht glauben also ich
muss das ganz ehrlich sagen weil boris
becker hat so viel erlebt in seiner in
seinem leben in seiner karriere und er
ist immer irgendwie wieder auch mit
einem blauen auge davon gekommen man hat
eben auch auch immer alles wieder
verziehen aber
jetzt gab es keine vergebung die
richterin hat keine gnade gezeigt und
hat das urteil gesprochen zweieinhalb
jahre für boris becker nach der hälfte
soll er das gefängnis wieder verlassen
können das ist also immer noch ein jahr
und drei monate die er dann im gefängnis
verbringen muss in london und die frage
war ja wird er dort heute abend noch hin
verbracht werden das wissen wir im
moment noch nicht auch das wird sich in
wenigen momenten wahrscheinlich klären
er hatte die tasche ja schon gepackt und
wird dann möglicherweise heute abend
schon die nacht in so einer zelle in ein
gefängnis in england verbringen müssen
boris becker muss ins gefängnis